las autoridades iraníes mantienen un
mismo discurso desde el principio de las
protestas en el país culpar a Estados
Unidos por no tolerar unirán fuerte e
independiente independiente
creemos que Estados Unidos está detrás
de la mayor parte de la destrucción el
terror los disturbios y el caos en la
región y en el mundo eso Afirma nuestra
creencia y la del mundo que los
estadounidenses están enfadados y
molestos por cada Innovación cada
felicidad o bien que le sucede a Irán
la animosidad entre los dos países no es
nueva hace 40 años que se auto señalan
como enemigos y que era indicar valores
Opuestos sobre todo en términos de
Derechos Humanos al inicio de las
protestas el gobierno de yobaidan mostró
rápidamente su apoyo a los manifestantes
y reafirmó el viernes estar al lado de
las valientes mujeres y herramientas
tiene que poner fin a la violencia
contra sus propios ciudadanos Por el
simple hecho de ejercer sus derechos
fundamentales pero si los manifestantes
siguen exigiendo más derechos para las
mujeres y dañes con todos los eslóganes
como ciertos actos simbólicos muestran
una frustración más global frente al
poder religioso y político
[Música]
es tienen un problema con este gobierno
todos salen a decir algo contra este
gobierno
no es solo en la muerte de maxa lo que
hace que la gente salga a la calle de
hecho es una herida que se suma a todas
las heridas que ellos han infligido
durante 43 años a todo el dolor que han
infligido al pueblo iraní y ahora
Estamos hartos la movilización entró en
su quinta semana y no parece perder
fuerza a pesar de una represión
extremadamente violenta por parte de las
autoridades según la ong y eran humanas
más de 100 personas fallecieron desde el
principio de las protestas incluyendo 23
menores